it's confirmed after weeks will they
won't they Prince Harry and Megan have
deigned to return their RSVP for the
king's coronation next month but guess
what only Harry is coming Megan is
staying behind in California with the
kids and the palace said they're pleased
to confirm Harry's attendance sources
close to the sussexes meanwhile saying
Prince Archie's fourth birthday which is
actually on the same day as the
coronation was a big factor in the
couple's decision but a child's fourth
birthday party really seems a little bit
like a convenient excuse for a more
personal decision for Megan to stay home
in Montecito and for once this probably
actually pleases both her critics and
her supporters it means she's staying
out of the Limelight while Harry gets to
come home even if it is only for a few
hours now it's something I've been
thinking about today amid these
accusations that President Biden quote
hates the UK we'll go into that a bit
later on
um how do we deal with the idea that
someone might be anti-british when a
figure we trust appears to abandon a
love for Britain I think it's not so
much about them as it is about us my
hunch is Harry has never been and will
never be anti-british he loves this
country but in this Rebellion over the
past few years his words and his actions
they've hurt us and the fact he's coming
back next month to be part of this
historic moment shows he does want to be
here but will we welcome him that very
much depends on us while joining me to
discuss all this broadcaster and
playwright Bonnie Greer lovely see you
again Bonnie and former press secretary
to the queen Dickie Arbiter thank you
both joining us down the line as well
former BBC Royal correspondent Jenny
Bond Jenny we were wondering whether you
complete the royal blue set this evening
but looking resplendent
resplendent in Tartan and Jenny given
you're joining us from home this evening
let's just start with you and ask uh
were you at all surprised by the
decision the announcement this afternoon
no I thought it was always going to turn
out this way and I think it's the best
solution actually uh Megan unfortunately
is a person who divides opinion I I she
probably doesn't wish to but she does
divide opinion and I think she was over
here then there would be a huge debate
about whether she was welcome or not she
might her presence would possibly
overshadow the coronation but it's
always been important that Harry should
be here be here for the biggest day in
his father's life really uh Charles has
made it clear that he still loves his
son whatever's going on that he wants
him to be there and so I'm very pleased
that Harry is coming and I think it's a
much better solution that Megan should
stay back in California with the
children quite reasonable Dickie coming
to you your knowledge of the protocol of
course the Royal household the palace uh
the late Queen it is the right decision
surely for Harry to attend this event
it's very much the right decision given
everything that's gone before the Oprah
interview the six hours of Netflix the
book uh and all the little bits of
interviews in between uh people
wonderful well how can you show his face
at the coronation but it is the right
decision his father loves him as Jenny
rightly said we heard in his uh his
first address following the death of his
mother where he sent his love to both
Harry and Megan in California so it is
the right decision what I do hope is
that it's not a distraction because what
will happen is the media will focus
their attention on him the photographers
will focus attention they'll haul out
out of the woodwork all the body
language experts and we'll get all sorts
of things I want to see us focusing on a
once in a lifetime for me it's the
second time because I saw the Queen's
coronation but I I want to see the focus
of attention on the king it's his day
and it's the the people of Britain's day
as well and certainly it seems to a big
distraction like you said anything about
Harry of course people be watching what
his relationship will be like with
William on the day as well perhaps we'll
come back to jail in that but first i'm
going to come to you Bonnie on Megan's
decision to stay behind in in Montecito
with the children
um I think there was no other way
shortly no that's absolutely right she
made her mother's decision she's still
got little children that is her son's
birthday uh she made the right decision
and I have to say I'm actually quite
moved in a way that Harry's decided to
do this it's very grown up it's very
proper uh it's a tribute to his Grand
who he loved and his father but most of
all his children and I'm putting my
historians hat on his children are
probably two of the most extraordinary
people ever born because on one side his
side they're descended from every Royal
head they that ever was including the
prophet and on their mother's side
through her mother they are descended
from my ancestors not my literal
ancestors but this but uh enslaved
Africans so you have this lovely
combination and one day Harry's going to
sit these kids down and say this is your
heritage too the other part that you
because these could be American kids
they're going to be brought up as
Americans they ain't going to be called
Prince Archie and Princess Lily bed in
the United States I would tell you that
but nevertheless they they will see this
other side and it it they're going to be
extraordinary individuals because of
that so I'm happy he's there because he
can say dad there's Dad I was there
shouldn't they be there then Lily but no
you're too little and I wouldn't I mean
I wouldn't bring them they are they are
far too young what do you think of the
king that he was at his mother's
coronation probably for about half an
hour
he was three years old no the children
should not be there this is not a
children's circus this is a very devout
service
it is a coronation it is anointing in
the eyes of God the king and therefore
know the children should not be there
they've got the right kids there uh
George playing a role and the other
children playing a role but no Archie
and Lily shouldn't be there and George
should be there he is the third line
sorry he is he is now let's get back to
Jenny on the distraction uh Point Jenny
uh the Dickie brought up surely the
presence of Harry in and of himself is
just going to be something of a media
circus is there any way around it
oh it will be it would have been more of
a media circus had Megan being here as
well but you know we've only got
ourselves to blame for this and I've
said for some months now that um if
Harry and Megan came or even just Harry
coming what we should do we the media
should say also in attendance was the
Duke of Sussex we don't need to go wild
about it we don't need to bring in the
body language experts that dick was
talking about of course we will of
course we will that's what we do but
we've earn ourselves to blame um but I I
agree and concur with uh Dicky that this
is Charles's day
um and that's where the focus should be
and I'm very sorry that in the leader to
the decision it's been and finally
announced today
um there's been so much attention on um
Harry and Megan I mean I think it is
rude that they've taken so long to
answer a very simple question you're
invited to this occasion are you coming
and it kept us on tender hoax for weeks
and weeks but but Jenny we were kept on
tender hooks because we wanted to be on
them okay we didn't have to pay so much
attention to them people do and it's not
necessary I agree with you about and
Dicky this is the King's day and this is
the King's day as long as we allow it to
be the King's day and I think that when
Harry comes I think he will contribute
to it being the King's day and not only
that his dad's day and I'm very proud of
him I think it's a very mature decision
and it's I like to qualify what Bolly
just said she said uh we make the
decision we the media make the decision
that it is focus of attention on the
king and on the queen consort and not on
everybody else that is there yes certain
people do have roles to play and they
will be seen visually uh portraying that
role but the congregation of which Harry
is a part of does not play a part in the
in the coronation ceremony and therefore
we in the media must Focus attention on
the big picture so this is your campaign
Dicky this evening to try and get the
media to listen but it won't happen yeah
it won't happen because there's all
kinds Dicky nose and Jenny knows there's
not just the media the print media there
is social media there's all kinds of
things happening they've been happening
for two weeks on social media so Harry
coming I think and where he will be
positioned and his and his uh uh
response to God Save the King and all of
that is going to be a deep focus but he
has to be there and I like I say I'm
proud that he's decided to come as part
of the fabric of History it does seem
imperative you were not doing along
vigorously when Jenny was saying it was
very rude of Harry Megan to hold up
did it take them a month to reply they
either he or she or they knew that they
were coming or they didn't Harry knew he
definitely had to be there and he should
have responded immediately without
waiting a month without all this
speculation that's gone on for over 30
days but Dicky we were speculating I
mean who knows why it took them that
long I don't know but we were
speculating I'm saying not you
personally no I wasn't I mean it's it's
the public that's speculating and the
and the the more that we take ourselves
away from these two individuals as
individuals let this ceremony happen I
know it won't be like that but just let
the ceremony happen it is Charles's day
he's been waiting for what 67 years for
it so let's just let him have his day
bringing Jenny back in on this because
it is as uh Dickey and Bonnie have been
pointing out it's it's Charles's day
it's the Kings days also the country's
day that's going to be Street parties it
should be a very jubilant Affair however
it this Harry visit of course will be
part of the circus as we've already
discussed
um
do you think that they can get past it
how do you think the royal family are
going to deal with this how do you think
they're going to instill this sense of
decorum
well it'll all go perfectly wonderfully
these vacations always do
um they will be polite and courteous to
one another William by definition has
got a very important role to play uh
during the coronation ceremony and
therefore I think he will be physically
apart from Harry so we won't be able to
analyze their every look that every
movement uh the two will be separated
um and there's no reason for them to to
meet at all because I think Harry's
going to fly straight in and straight
out as he did quite recently through a
court case apparently without seeing
anyone uh so there may be no meeting
between the two brothers and the
animosity between two the two obviously
is still very very deep
um so I think it will all go as smoothly
as these Royal occasions do go and we
will all try to draw some kind of
conclusions
um about how they're looking at each
other but none of it will be realistic I
don't think
um I think the tensions are so deep and
the Rifts so hurt for at the moment that
is going to take more than a flying
visit by by Harry to put things right
um just before we wrap up I want to ask
you both briefly do you think the
British public is going to be welcoming
to Harry Dickey the British public going
to be welcoming for the coronation it's
the King's day and they're going to
focus on the Kings Day and everybody
else is just there Harry is going to
find it very difficult he's going to
feel very lonely because he's fallen out
with his family he is there as a matter
of Duty but he's got no support his
wife's thousands of miles away in
California and he's going to hack this
one alone yeah well someone privileged
to be a British citizen for a long time
now and watching funerals and weddings
the British people will stand right up
to this it'll be beautiful they'll let
it all smooth out and here he will go
home back to Montecito it'll be fine